Let me,
let me give this guy a trance because things are bad.
The media is lying to me.
Wall Street's line to me.
And so,
you know,
Trump,
Trump won,
but unfortunately now Trump is part of the establishment.
Uh,
and now all of a sudden the fake economic numbers are legit.
Now every time there's an unemployment number out,
he tweets about how it's the lowest at separate pen.
So I think that when we get this next recession,
which is going to happen while Trump is president during,
during this first term,
which I think will be the only term,
but when all the people,
why do you think those two things?
Well,
because I think the economy is going to fall into a severe recession.
What makes you say that?
Well,
a,
you know,
it's,
we're overdue,
right?
I mean,
you don't normally have an expansion that lasts as long as this one.
I think that we're,
we're the second longest in history and if we go for another year,
it will be the longest expansion
history.
2008 is when it started to turn around.
And that was a nine kind of the end of 2009 years in exactly what does a usual
expansion and compression,
I don't know,
five,
six years.
So,
so this
one is long,
but it also,
this one required more government stimulus than any other,
you know,
or recovery.
And I don't think we actually recovered.
I think the government simply,
you know,
injected a bunch of cheap money into the economy and exacerbated the real
problems.
But you know,
reflated the bubbles in the stock market and the housing market.
everybody talks about how the economy is doing so great,
but it's really not much better than it was under Obama.
If it's any better at all.
And we've GDP growth for Trump's first year in office last year was 2.3%.
I mean,
nothing great.
First quarter was 2%.
Um,
this quarter might be a better than three,
maybe,
maybe not.
But I mean,
I think it's going to be the second quarter.
We'll probably be the best quarter of the year.
Maybe we're probably going to go downhill.
But you know,
last year was I think the,
the weakest year of job growth since 2011.
So people want to talk about how great everything is,
but it's more a function of people are hoping things are gonna turn around and
there's a lot of optimism now,
but things are going to get better.
But I think that the people who are so optimistic,
a lot of them are going to be disappointed because we're,
we're going to end up with is a weaker economy.
The only thing that's really strengthened and inflation inflation is going to
pick up.
So the cost of living is really going to be rising as the economy is falling
into recession.
So we get stagflation,
uh,
which is probably the worst possible economic scenario.
And you know,
I think that the,
uh,
the left and even the Fed is going to be able to blame it on Trump because Trump
has come in and,
you know,
claim credit for this great economy that he believes we have.
And he's claimed credit for the records in the stock market,
but he's basically put his name on a bubble and when it pops,
you know it's going to be hard for him to try to blame the next recession on
Obama when he's already said,
hey,
this is my economy.
I created it.
And so people are going to be disappointed and they're going to vote I think for
uh,
another person whose promises change and unfortunately that's going to come from
the left.
So you think this is going to happen within the next three years?
Well,
yeah.
I mean what is the bubble like?
What do you think is going to cause it to crash?
Commercial real estate?
Is it credit?
What is it?
Well,
I mean,
commercial real estate is expensive being it's in a bubble,
but that,
you know,
that's not going to cause it.
I mean air's going to come out of the bubble.
I think we would already be in a pretty severe recession.
Now had it not been for Trump winning had Hillary won.
I think we would already be there.
But I think that makes you say that,
well we got a lot of false optimism as a result of,
of Trump.
And we did get the tax cuts and the tax cuts.
You know,
just like you know,
any kind of artificial drug,
you know,
you can inject yourself and get a little bit of a phony high.
Uh,
because remember the tax cuts were paid for with debt.
We didn't shrink government.
Right?
If you,
if you make government smaller,
that's great,
then you can cut taxes because now the government doesn't need as much money and
you can,
you know,
you can relieve the taxpayer of the burden of paying for it and that's great.
But if you just cut taxes but you don't cut government spending.
And of course what the Trump administration did was,
was even worse.
They increase government spending,
we increased welfare spending,
we increased warfare spending.
Uh,
and so spending is more,
but they reduced their tax revenues.
So the deficits are just exploding out of control and those deficits are going
to do more damage to the economy than the tax cuts were benefit.
Except you get the benefit first,
maybe for the first year,
and then you start to deal with the pain after that.
And so I think that's going to set in a,
you know,
long before the end of Trump's term.
So you think that this is what is causing the economy to be in a really,
at least a two to look like it's in a really healthy state right now.
Well,
some of the numbers,
right?
Some of the numbers look better.
Um,
but beneath the surface,
again,
it's not improving just like it just like it wasn't improving under Obama.
That's what laid the foundation for Trump's victory was because Obama and
everybody kept talking about how great the recovery was.
But the average voter knew that that was all a bunch of nonsense because he
wasn't living in that reality.
So if you were the financial advisor to the president,
what would you tell him?
How would you,
what would you do to try to keep the economy moving in the same direction?
Is it possible to ward off when you kind of a crash?
Right.
And we don't want to keep it moving in the same direction.
I mean,
it's in the same direction it was going in before Trump came in.
And that's towards the edge of a cliff.
I mean,
so what we do,
we need it is,
is it about face and Trump has not doing that.
I mean about face woods for the people that are listening to this that don't
understand,
like they,
they're saying,
okay,
the economy supposed to be doing well,
a black unemployment is the lowest it's ever been on.
Unemployment is down.
All these jobs have been created.
Yeah.
Well remember again,
the unemployment rate is mainly down because so many people that are unemployed
are no longer counted as part of the statistics.
So you know that,
that's if you look at the labor force participation rate near record low,
I mean certainly for men,
uh,
it's the lowest it's been in the history of the republic.
Um,
but,
and look at the,
you know,
workers to population.
So fewer and fewer people are actually working and more and more of the people
who aren't working are not included in the unemployment statistics.
So if you backed all those people in,
right,
able bodied people who don't have jobs but should be working,
then the unemployment rate is much,
much higher.
So that that doesn't really paint a good picture.
And then,
you know,
you look at the fact that so many Americans are unqualified,
right?
There's a lot of jobs out there that go on Phil because American workers aren't
qualified to fill those positions.
Because,
you know,
we,
we take a lot of our kids and we keep them in high school until they're 1819
years old.
Many of these kids should drop out of high school and learn a trade.
I mean,
a lot of people,
you know,
they don't have the aptitude for academics.
There's no point in just being in high school.
A lot of times they're glorified daycare centers,
but they should be out learning trades.
And of course we make it harder for employers to train people on the job with
occupational licensing laws and minimum wage laws.
So we destroy a lot of the opportunities for younger kids to get skills.
And then the ones that we send the college,
they waste their time,
you know,
majoring in liberal arts.
So they spend four or five,
six years in college learning nothing of any real value in the market.
They accumulate a massive amount of debt in the process.
And so,
you know,
we have a labor force that's highly educated and that they've got a bunch of
degrees.
Maybe they didn't learn anything,
but they've got a piece of paper.
But then what they have is a lot of debt.
And so we don't have a lot of people qualified to do a lot of the things that
need to be done.
So what would you tell the president if you were,
if you,
he said,
look,
Peter Schiff,
uh,
I don't know shit about the economy.
You obviously do help me out.
How do you stop this bubble?
Well,
first of all,
you can't stop it.
You got to let it to fleet.
But the question is how does it deflate?
And then what do you propose as the solution?
See the problem that Trump already made was when he first got elected,
he should not have changed his perspective.
He shouldn't have said,
hey,
everything is great right now.
He's planning on running.
His next campaign is keep America great.
Right?
When Trump ran for office,
he said America was an economic wasteland,
that it was a disaster.
He's been president for a little over a year.
All of a sudden it's the greatest economy in the history of the country,
which is not even close to being true.
But if he's going to try to run for reelection on,
I've already made America great and now we just want to keep it great.
That's not gonna resonate.
So what he should have done from day one is leveled with the American public.
Again,
this is how bad the problem is and this is what it's going to take to solve it
because there's a lot of,
you know,
um,
pain,
short term pain that we're going to need to go through in order to come to the
other side.